معنا من القدس مراسله الجزيره نجوان
السمري نجوان هل من معلومات اضافيه
لهم بتنفيذ هذه العمليه هذا هو التوجه
الاول للشرطه
الاسرائيليه
الحديث يدور عن انفجار واقعه قرد محطه
حافلات رايسيه عند المدخل الرئيسي لمدينه
القدس من الجهه الغربيه
الحرجه تم نقل الغالبيه المصابين الى
المستشفيات الاسرائيليه بالاضافه الى
تعامل همم
طارق اقل من الساعه وقع هناك انفجار اخر
في منطقه اخرى في مدينه القدس
نموت خلفيه هذا الانفجار الثاني ما زال
عند صفحه هذه اللحظه وبحسب المصادر الطبيه
الاسرائيليه لا توجد اصابات جزاء هذا
الانفجار الشرطه الاسرائيليه اغلقت المدخل
الرئيسي لمدينه القدس واغلقت مقطع من شارع
محوريثه شارع رقم واحد الذي يصل بين مدينه
تل ابيب ومدينه
القدس وتواصل عمليات التحقيق من خلال جمع
بيكاميرات المراقبه في المنطقه وجمع
شهادات من شهود عيان الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه تعمل
لكل اجراءها الشرطه
والمخابرات وقوات اخرى هناك حاله من همم
الصدمه في الشارع الاسرائيلي جلال هذا
الانفجاران صباحا هذا اليوم في مدينه
القدس وانه لم تكن هناك معلومات
حتى هذه اللحظه